olá a todos e que não sabe por que não
anda tentou mesmo instagram eu ando
construir o meu estúdio novo estúdio
onde eu vou começar a gravar a fazer
tudo o que seja relacionado ao canal e
eu estou aqui dentro de si mesmo estúdio
mas não como está a ficar estou a ficar
brutal basicamente nestes últimos quatro
dias eu tenho andado a trazer as coisas
da minha casa aqui para dentro do
estúdio vai ser o sítio onde eu vou
começar a fazer os vídeos vai ser o
local onde eu vou começar a trabalhar a
séria mesmo no canal jato para construir
este estudo a 2 foi quem é nos mosteiros
à tua espera estar muito tempo
finalmente vou conseguir captar vídeos
todos os dias eu vou conseguir fazer
vídeos da noite também que era uma coisa
que eu adorava fazer e que eu não
conseguir fazer o que tinha que fazer
sempre outro manhã ou mesmo muito à
tarde porque também comandava as outras
pessoas outras pessoas se incomodavam a
mim com o barulho que vinha de fora e
foi por isso que eu construir aquela
mini carvana dentro do meu quarto o que
me ajudou um pouco mais do que eu já não
estava a funcionar tão bem eo melhor é
mesmo a fazer é ir para outro sítio um
dado de casa ou então achar um estúdio
que foi o caso eu tive muita sorte mesmo
porque foi o pai de catarina conseguiu
achar espaço por isso muito obrigado
mesmo
obrigada catarina também um apelo à
ajuda como está a dar é porque ela está
me ajudando muito
é basicamente um destes quatro de estiva
que a tentar mudar as coisas da minha
casa para o estúdio já tenha que a maior
parte do meu setup não falta as coisas
dos armários meus bonecos minhas coisas
que andavam ambiente que eu estava no
meu quarto eu vi que o time teve
perguntas posses gostariam de ver um
minibolo hoje ea maior parte das pessoas
disseram que eu sempre estou agora aqui
fazer este blog eu sei que está tudo
arrumado mas diz que ainda está em
construção eu vou acabar estudo hoje o
que tem nada que fazer é basicamente
acumular essas esponjas acústicas nesta
parede de vidro porque esta por ele é
todo em vidro a toda em vidro e como
você estava em vidro urbana com ruído
urbano com o som e não faltou aqui estas
partes ainda faltar aqui mas eu ainda
tenha sua esposa ator e não vou ter que
cortar ainda vou ter claro eu vou usar
silicone para quem tem dúvidas de
plástico já usa em silicone o turismo
porque eu saí star game é de que o tempo
é dificuldade claro esponjas meu uso
explicou porque está a resultar eu nem
sabia que isso funcionava e eu acho que
isso não estraga preto pelo menos isso
não estragou vidro apenas fica foi para
caraças
como vocês podem ver aqui deste lado vez
um banho está foi o caraças mas funciona
isso funciona isto collaço projetor e eu
não sabia que funcionava eu não me caso
uma cola que temos um com o preto porque
quando arranquei esponja foi publicado
de parede atrás e isso é muito bom para
quem os anti preto eu acho que clicou em
paredes assim mais normais eu acho que
também funciona porque explicou que tipo
de borracha que eu acho que não há
ranking aparece nestas condições foi
catarina com o tema difícil controlar
aqui esta pureza o que eu vou fazer é
vou colocar tipo umas molduras com as
caras dos animais tronics com coisas que
eu gosto relacionadas jogos ele o fundo
vamos ter uma tela verde para conseguir
fazer outros tipos de vídeos que estou a
pensar fazer não é que nesta temporada
assim enfrentá-los e tanto eu vou
colocar uma estante com um monte de
coisas e eu temos mostram que mais
homens como é qualquer perfil geral
deste gênero este é o armário da
catarina onde ela tem os filmes dela tem
menos filmes meu beijo e isto é tudo
filmes de terror mesmo a sério ela tem
muito filme aqui ok vou ter que estudar
e vocês já perceberam que ele fora tem
muito mais eco do que aqui dentro
obviamente porque eu já estou claro
esponja
então aqui o áudio já está muito melhor
mas basicamente é isso o lado minutos
vou mostrar mas também estamos a montar
o estúdio da catarina que ela vai
começar a trabalhar e também fazer os
vídeos mas ela depois mostrei isso então
à mostra depois melhor em outro vídeo
está apenas um vídeo muito rápido para
vos dizer que o toma mudar as coisas vão
mudar as coisas vão ficar melhor e que
eu vou conseguir por estar finalmente
vídeos todos os dias e trabalhar na
mesma série como eu queria e vocês já
perceberam é que o dueto de bullet to
compõem energia eu tô com vontade de
fazer vídeos eu vou despachar estou seu
amanhã vou tentar ter visto de pronto é
continental meu a ser se não gostar mas
nenhum vídeo até o natal
a estatal já ele 22.000 ser eu nem sabia
pensava que a etnia dos ossos então é
isso só vou continuar aqui claro
esponjas governo acaba muito rápido para
voltar em grande com o canal
obrigado por tudo o que fazemos tem dado
até agora eu sei que é difícil apoiar um
canal quando a pessoa parece que não se
esforça o momento muitos vídeos mas não
é bem assim porque eu tenho me esforçado
muito possam ter muitos vídeos mas por
trás das câmeras e thomas forçarem mesmo
pra que isto resulte para que o envie
no meu futuro e prontinho agradeço os
mesmo por vocês continuarem a apoiar uma
pessoa que parece que não está assim tão
esforçava fazer as coisas mas não se
enganem não é falta de esforço porque eu
me esforçar muito e mesmo simplesmente
não poder fazer as coisas como elas
deveriam ser feitas eu gosto de fazer as
coisas bem feitas e por isso eu preciso
ter um espaço agradável espaço bom para
que eu consiga fazer as coisas porque
não tive só porque sim e depois vocês
não vão gostar e eu também não ia custar
isso não ia dar em nada então eu prefiro
investir agora nisto e depois fazer as
coisas já serei as coisas como eu gosto
e obrigado por me acompanharem mesmo que
não possua antivírus mas obrigado mesmo
cérebro é bom é isso fique bem e até a
próxima se não está nada feliz natal